HELEN SWORD: Well,
thank you, Amy and Judy,
for organizing this.
And thank you, Steve and
Elizabeth, for taking part.
Judy mentioned sort
of a formative moment
as a graduate student.
And I'll start with one of mine.
When I was doing
my PhD at Princeton
in comparative literature,
I remember a moment
at the end of my first year
when somebody in my department
was in his second year and was
just taking his general exams,
PhD qualifying exams.
And so we all clustered
around him afterwards.
And we said, how'd it go?
How'd it go?
And he said, oh, I think
it went really well.
I've just spent the last hour
writing about the slippage
of the signifier.
And I thought, I don't
even know what that means.
But of course, by a year
later when I took my exams,
I had made damn sure that
I knew what it meant.
And also, I'm pretty
sure that I managed
to get that phrase into my exam,
because I could tell that it
sounded really impressive.
And so that was one of those
moments when I internalized
this idea that being
an academic writer
was primarily about
impressing other academics
with your erudition.
I've come to believe
that it is or should
be about communicating
effectively,
whether with colleagues or with
people outside of the academy.
And I think learning to make
that distinction was also
an important part
of my education.
I went on from there, then, to
teach in an English department
for about 10 years.
I wrote a couple of books
of literary criticism.
I prided myself that
they were well-written.
I thought of myself
as a good writer.
And I think I did manage
to avoid the worst
temptations of jargon that
people in that discipline
in particular can fall into.
And yet, I would go to
academic conferences,
and people would come up
and say, loved your book.
And that was great.
There was a real
sense of communicating
with the colleagues.
But I would give a
copy to my mother.
And she'd flip through
the first chapter.
And she'd say, my, you
know a lot of big words.
So the moment for
me when I really
started to think about academic
writing more broadly outside
of my discipline came maybe
seven or eight years ago,
when I shifted into working in
faculty development and higher
education research.
And so I was charged with
developing and teaching
on a program that was for
faculty at my university who
wanted to become more
research-informed teachers.
So I naturally went out, trying
to find readings for them.
I wanted to find people
working in higher education
research who could
kind of summarize
the best of that
research so that people
could benefit from that
research in their own teaching.
Found plenty of good
books that did that,
and I could pull chapters
out of those books.
And I think there's a
lesson there that the bar is
higher with book publishing.
You go through a
lot more-- you have
to step through
a lot more gates.
But when I looked in the top
international higher education
research journals, what I found
were a whole bunch of articles
that, by and large, were,
at best, wooden and dry,
at worst, spongy and soggy,
and that really seemed
to be communicating--
they seemed
to be higher education
researchers trying
to impress other
higher education
researchers with their jargon,
and with their language,
and with their methodology.
And most of these
articles I couldn't use.
At first, I thought maybe
it was just because I
came from literary studies.
And maybe it was just me.
So I did distribute a few
of these to my colleagues.
So these would be people from
law, population health, music,
engineering.
And they pretty much
all said, no, we
don't want to read this stuff.
Don't understand it.
They're taking 20 pages to
say something they could
say in five pages, et cetera.
And that was when I started to
think there's something wrong
here if people who are doing
research on higher education
teaching and learning
cannot-- are either not able
to or can't be bothered to
communicate that research
to other people working in
higher education teaching
and learning-- so educated
people with PhDs--
then what are
those articles for?
What are they doing?
So at that point,
I decided to do
a little bit of empirical
research of my own.
I sent out an email
basically to everybody
I knew and asked them to send
it on to everybody they knew.
And I asked a
couple of questions.
I asked, what is your definition
of stylish academic writing?
And it isn't intentionally
oxymoronic and slightly
provocative phrase.
Not everybody likes
the word stylish.
If that doesn't
ring your bell, you
can replace it with
engaging, or even just
effective academic writing.
So if you ask yourself
the same questions,
think of who are the
writers in your field
who really engage you and who,
when you read their writing,
you think, I would like
to write like that.
And then think about
what is it that they do?
What are the characteristics
of their writing?
That is stylish
academic writing.
So I got back responses
from more than 70 people
from around the world and
across the disciplines.
And what I found
astonishing was how,
despite the disciplinary
differences, how consistent
their responses were.
They pretty much all said,
in one way or another,
that they value people
who take complex ideas
and communicate them clearly,
or if not clearly-- because
not every discipline values
clarity as much as others.
Some actually value opacity.
But still, there is the
idea that they communicate
complex ideas in a
way that illuminates
those ideas for their reader.
They talked about the
importance of communication.
They would say, I like
authors who tell a story.
I like authors who
use lots of examples
to illustrate whatever it
is they're talking about.
And this came whether, it
was people in the science,
or humanities, social sciences.
And so from that list and
also from looking at examples
of some of the writers that
they particularly recommended,
I made a kind of 10
point, you could call it
a grading rubric, 10 things that
the stylish academic writers
usually do.
So there are things
like they usually
have an engaging title, a
title that kind of says,
come read me.
I've gone to some
work with this.
They usually have
an opening paragraph
that really pulls you in.
They usually use lots
and lots of examples.
They usually do have a sense
of a story they're telling.
They always have
well-crafted sentences.
So you might prefer
concision in your writing.
Or you might prefer really
long, complex syntax.
But either way,
the stylish writers
are the ones who have
really taken the time
to make those
sentences well-crafted.
Pretty much everybody
in this room
would probably agree
on those things.
So I took this 10 point list.
And then I checked
it against a number
of the stylish academic writers
who had been recommended.
Steve was on the list.
And I did my best to find, not
just books by these people,
but articles where possible,
so that I wouldn't be comparing
apples with oranges, rated these
writers on the 10 point scale.
And most of them
came out-- I think
the average score for 10
people across the disciplines
was about 9.1, which isn't
too surprising, because I'd
constructed the rubric
based on what they do.
But it was just
to make the point
that it is possible to
write academic articles that
do these things and to publish
them in a range of journals.
Then I looked at 100
articles from basically
the six highest rated higher
education research journals.
And I rated them on the
same 10 point scale.
Anyone want to take a guess
that at average score out of 10
possible?
I heard a four.
I saw three.
2.5-- you were all optimists.
[LAUGHTER]
The mean score was 1.1.
The median score was zero.
More than half did none
of these 10 things.
And again, you just have to
look at that and say, why?
What is going on here?
Why would the authors of
these journal articles
not do any of the
things that we all
know you can do to make
your work more engaging
and readable?
And I think the reason
is, well, there are
various institutional reasons.
But they kind of boil down
to convention and fear,
people actually
thinking that they
have to write that way in
order to get published.
So I actually wrote an article
based on that research ,
got it published
in the top journal,
Studies in Higher Education,
to prove the point that
the editors actually are looking
for things that are engaging,
as long as the research
has to be there.
There can't be empty style
without the substance.
At that point, I decided
to broaden my research
and look at academic writing
across the disciplines, which
has been just
absolutely fascinating.
I stopped using
the grading rubric,
because I didn't want to
be pitting-- you know,
it's not fair.
And in some
disciplines, if you're
looking at a medical journal,
where people are writing
a seven page, very
formulaic [INAUDIBLE]
of a five year research project.
You're not expecting the
snazzy introduction and things.
You have readers who want to
come in and just sort of mine
it for the facts.
But those same writers
in the sciences
also have the moments when
they need to communicate with,
for instance, the tenure
and promotion committees
or the grant writing
committees, when
actually having those more
stylish strategies would
be very useful for them,
the ones that engage
and persuade people.
So I started looking.
I looked at 1,000
articles, 100 each
from 10 different disciplines
across the sciences,
the social sciences, and
the arts and humanities
and found that while,
in most disciplines,
things aren't quite as dire as
they are in higher education,
still a strikingly high number
of disciplines-- of academics
in pretty much all
disciplines are very much
ruled by convention, which I
find interesting for academics.
Because I think of
being an academic
as being about pushing the
boundaries of knowledge.
And yet, a lot of
the training that we
do with our graduate students
is about disciplining them,
fitting them within.
And so there's a real
kind of difficulty there.
So by the time I'd
done that research,
I also looked at well over
probably 150 books and articles
by people who had been
recommended to me by colleagues
in their own fields as
stylish academic writers.
And I decided in the book not
to focus on the negative side,
the bad side.
Turns out, I'm very good at
doing these really snarky
close readings of
really bad sentences,
and I quite enjoy doing it.
But it makes people
feel bad, you know.
And if you want
to change things,
you don't do it by
criticizing people.
You do it by inspiring them.
So I tried to find the
inspiring examples.
And the book is full of these
little spotlights on style,
where I've taken
particular writers
and done close readings of
their works, their sentences
and paragraphs, to
try to demystify
what stylish writing is.
Yes, some people
are more talented
and more skillful at
writing than others.
But they are all
using techniques
that anybody can learn.
And so I tried to
really break down
what they were doing into
the specific techniques
that they use.
At the beginning of
the book, I talked
about three characteristics
of stylish writing
that I think go across
the board, no matter
what the discipline.
So style can vary.
We can all have different
stylistic preferences.
But stylish academic writers, I
think, always, always, always,
are concerned with
communication.
So that's one of
the characteristics.
Another is that I think they
are always concerned with craft.
As I've already said, it
could be a short sentence,
a long one, but as long as
it's a well-crafted sentence.
And the point there
is that the author
is doing the work, not expecting
the reader to do the work.
And think about that when
you're reading something
where you're really
plowing through it
and trying to figure it out.
It's probably because the
author hasn't actually
taken the time to work it
and work it and work it.
This may seem really obvious
to most of you sitting here,
but I don't think it's obvious
always to our students.
I've heard a lot of
graduate students say,
you know, I'm not
a very good writer.
And it's so frustrating.
It's the same story of
getting all the red pen back.
And this is a bad thing.
My supervisor is a
really good writer.
And then I write these
things, and it's just mush.
And I have to work on it and
work on it and work on it
to make it any better.
And it's so hard.
And it's so frustrating.
And I'm just not
really very good.
Then you go, and you
talk to the supervisor.
And this is some of the research
I'm doing now, interviewing
academics about their writing.
And they'll say, oh, when
I write the first draft,
it's just mush.
It's a big mess.
But then I work on it, and I
work on it, and I work on it.
And I craft it.
And I'm an artisan of words.
And I work on it.
And it's hard, but
it's so satisfying,
getting it to where it gets
better and better and better.
Right, same story from
those two different people.
But one of them is seeing it
as this horrible frustration,
because they don't understand
that that's actually
what it takes to write
the stylish prose.
And so I've come to believe that
one of the qualities of-- one
of the sort of human qualities
that goes with stylish writing
is a pleasure in the craft.
Until you acquire that
pleasure in the craft,
you won't necessarily want
to put in the hard yards
to get there.
So communication
craft, and the third C
that I write about
in the introduction
is creativity, by which
I don't mean necessarily
that academics are or should
be bringing techniques
from creative writing into
their academic writing,
although some
people do that very
deliberately and effectively.
I mean that what I noticed
amongst the stylish writers I
looked at is that
they don't adhere
to convention if the
convention doesn't suit them.
And they are constantly
pulling in ideas
from other disciplines.
Again, if you think of the
top people in your own field,
think of what they do,
either stylistically
or in terms of the research.
And you'll find
that most of them
are quite
intradisciplinary thinkers.
I've seen this again and again.
They're reading widely.
They're bringing in ideas
from outside the discipline.
And that's precisely how they're
pushing the discipline forward.
So for teaching our students
that being an academic
is about adhering to
convention, we're actually
teaching them not to be in
that kind of top tier, I think.
By the time I finished the book,
I'd come up with three more
C's.
Helps me remember
them-- good mnemonic.
And so these were things that
I wasn't necessarily looking
for at the beginning.
But by the time I had finished,
I had really noticed them.
One of them is actually
more a technique
than an overall principle,
which is concreteness.
I saw this again and again,
whether in the science writing
or the humanities or
anywhere in between,
that the writers that most
of us find the most engaging
are the ones who use concrete
language and concrete examples,
particularly when they're
talking about abstract ideas.
Now, being an academic
is all about abstraction.
That's the whole point.
The definition of research is
the advancement of knowledge
or the creation of new
generalizable knowledge.
That act of generalizing is, in
essence, an act of abstraction.
So it's not a matter of
saying you won't be abstract.
It's a matter of communicating
those abstract ideas
through concrete language.
And I just, I notice
it again and again.
Sometimes it's just
through the use,
the choice of verbs and nouns.
And that's why we have so
much language in academe.
Some of it kind of turns into
dead metaphors at some point.
But that's why we talk
about exploring ideas
and about constructing
theoretical frameworks.
Those are concrete
terms that we're
using to just kind of give us
something we can visualize.
And my favorite example
of how this works
comes, not from a piece
of academic writing,
although you could find
many examples of it again.
I'm sure you think about this,
Steve, when you're writing.
Because you certainly do it.
But it's from a
political speech.
Martin Luther King's
"I Have a Dream" speech
is about abstract
concepts, right?
It's about freedom and
injustice and all these things.
But the way that he
communicates those ideas
is relentlessly concrete.
So he'll say, "I
have a dream that one
day in the red hills of Georgia,
the sons of former slaves
and the sons of
former slave owners
will be able to
sit down together
at the table of brotherhood."
He ends with the abstract noun.
But by the time he gets
you to the brotherhood,
he's taken you to a place,
the red hills of Georgia,
giving you this visual.
He's given you these people,
the sons of the slaves
and the sons of
the slave owners.
He's given you an action.
They sit down
together at a place,
at the table of brotherhood.
"I have a dream that my four
little children will one day
be able to be judged, not
by the color of their skin,
but by the content
of their character."
Same thing-- he gives
you the particulars.
He gives you the visual image.
And then he gives
the abstraction,
the content of your character.
So if this is something that
you don't normally think about,
and I'm sure some of
you do, but if it's not
something you've thought
about much before,
pay attention to it
when you're reading
or when you're listening.
I particularly like the genre
of the school graduation speech.
You know, so the
principal will be
talking about striving for
the attainment of excellence
and all this sort of thing.
And everybody is
kind of nodding off.
And then at some point, they'll
go, let me tell you a story.
And they tell you a story
of a former student who
has attained excellence.
And suddenly, you perk up
again, because you're back
in the concrete world.
You're in the world of
bodies that we live in.
So concreteness-- that
was, as a technique,
that would be, for
me, the number one
that really came
out of that book.
Telling stories goes with that.
But that's of forming, of
making things concrete.
Another of the sort of
overall principles is choice.
And what I found
from my research
is that in most disciplines,
at any given time,
you actually have
choices about style.
And again, I hear a lot
of early career academics,
grad students, say that
they can't do things
because they're not allowed to.
So a classic example
of that that I
investigated a bit in the
book is pronoun usage, right?
Can you or can you not use
first person pronouns, I and we?
The number of times
people have said
to me, particularly
social scientists,
we're not allowed to use the
first person, and then I go
and I look at the journals
in their discipline.
And it may not be conventional
to use the first person,
but there will always be one
article where somebody does,
one out of 10 or
something like that.
The social scientists
will say, well,
we're not allowed to
use the first person,
because we have to
sound like scientists.
I looked at three
scientific disciplines.
I looked at evolutionary
biology, computer science,
and medicine.
And I found that in all of
them, 80% or more of the authors
used we.
And all of the style
guides in every discipline
say, go ahead and use
first person pronouns.
I couldn't find a
single one, including
APA, used by most people
in social sciences,
that says, use the passive voice
and don't include yourself.
And yet, it's persisted
as this kind of myth.
The most surprising
finding for me
was that, of the 10
disciplines I looked at,
the one where first person
pronouns were used least
was not in the sciences.
It wasn't in the
social sciences.
It was in history.
So in history, I found that
of the sample I looked at,
100 articles, about
40% used first person
pronouns and about 60% did not.
In contrast to literary
studies, a neighboring genre,
very similar in many
ways-- and there
is something like 98% used
first person pronouns.
So I went, and I talked
to the history department
at my university.
And I showed them
these statistics.
And I said, explain this to me.
Why don't you use-- you write
in a very personal style,
generally.
It's not-- most historians
are not pretending
to be completely objective.
But they're doing that
through other means,
not through the first person.
And so the chair of the
department stuck up his hand.
And he said, well, I don't
use first person pronouns
because Professor
So-and-So at Oxford
told me in 1978 that
I must never do so.
And he had never since then
actually questioned that.
Now, if 60% are not using
personal pronouns and 40% are,
that suggests to me that
if you're a historian,
you have a choice.
It is your choice.
It is not the convention that
is choosing things for you.
So I would encourage
academics, and particularly
again early career academics
who are learning the genres,
to learn them in terms
of choices they make,
rather than in
terms of conventions
they have to follow.
But that brings me to the
final C, which is courage.
I think it takes courage to
be a stylish academic writer,
to push on that oxymoron.
And it can be difficult to
be courageous, particularly
if you're early in your career.
So another one of
the stories I hear
a lot from the graduate students
and pre-tenured academics
is, well, so-and-so who's a
really great writer-- Steve
Pinker, yeah, he writes
in a more personal style.
But he's allowed to,
because he's famous.
And he's got tenure
and all this.
So I've been interviewing.
The project I'm doing
now, I've kind of
shifted from looking
at academic style
to talking to the people
who write the books.
So I'm looking at people.
And by the time I
finish this trip,
I will have interviewed more
than 100 academics from all
across the disciplines and from
about 15 different countries,
all people who have been
recommended by colleagues, not
necessarily as stylish
writers, just as people
who are interesting writers
or interested in writing
or seem to just be able
to be productive writers
and also to raise a family,
or have a normal life,
or whatever.
So I'm just talking to
them and asking them
lots of questions
about how they learned
to write, what their
daily habits are,
what their emotions are.
And then I've been asking
some of the same questions
on a questionnaire, too.
By the end, I'll have
about 1,000 people
who will have-- so
academics from grad students
through to emeriti
professors who will
have answered those questions.
And one of the things that
I've been asking particularly
the successful, the
well-known writers is,
is this true that you
waited until after you
had tenure to start kind of
pushing the envelope on style?
So I interviewed
Douglas Hofstadter,
the author of
Godel, Escher, Bach,
which he started writing
when he was 28 years old.
He won the Pulitzer
Prize for it.
And it made his academic career.
And he, of course, said,
this is complete nonsense.
I made my academic career
by having written a book
that was unusual and that didn't
adhere to any academic genre.
So I do hear the
stories of people
who submit things to journals.
And they get pushed back.
They get told to chop out
all the interesting bits,
or to take out the first
person, or whatever.
But I've also heard a
lot of wonderful stories
of resistance, of going back
to the editor and negotiating,
or of sending the paper
to another journal
and then winning the
prize for the best article
for doing precisely the things
that somebody else told them
they couldn't do.
That takes confidence.
That takes courage.
But I think it's something that
it's worth it for all of us
to push on ourselves, but
in particular, to encourage
our students to do,
so to encourage them
to be the courageous
writers, rather than
the frightened,
conventional ones.
So I'll end there and see
what these two have to say.
[APPLAUSE]